♪ Ой, на Івана та й на Купала, ♪
♪ Ой, на Івана, ой та й на Купала, ♪
♪ Там дівчинонька цвіточки рвала. ♪
♪ Цвіточки рвала, віночки плела, ♪
♪ Ой, на Івана та й на Купала... ♪
[аплодують]
Це таке в нас село — дуже красиве.
Хто не приїде,
так каже — зелене, гарне.
[сміється]
Ципоньки, ципу-ципу-ципу...
Ципоньки!
Бо півень її б'є... Вийшли всі?
Ципу-ципу-ципу...
Іди до мене! Іди, моє маленьке!
Моє хороше і красиве!
Таке вже ж гарненьке, таке вже гарне!
[сміється]
Це був 1956 рік, приїхала у Пирятин.
Бо я вихованка Майорщинського дитячого будинку.
Це біля Пирятина.
І мені заврайоно дав направлення,
хоч було два направлення:
у [Велику] Кручу і в Крячківку.
Але інспектор сидів і каже:
«Та вона через місяць вийде заміж
за льотчика і полетить.  Хай їде в Крячківку».
Мені вже 71. У мене батьки дуже любили співати.
Батько дуже гарно співав...
Бабуся, це мамина мати...
І, напевно, трохи передалось і мені.
І в школі танцювала, співала.
І в ансамбль мене взяли у 1993 році.
Це 1984 рік, Лісова Поляна.
Ми були... Нас запросили від України,
і ми там [були].
А потім уже змінювались колективи.
Оце вже скільки [років] я у «Древі»,
то вже змінилося аж два колективи.
Ось керівник наш — Галина Якимівна.
Із самого початку,
з 1960 року вона — керівник.
Її немає вісім років, то дуже така була...
Галина Якимівна була [така] людина,
якій не потрібно було записувати пісні.
Усе тримала в голові.
Надумала якусь пісню і тоді дзвонить до нас:
«Прийдіть сьогодні, я здумала там пісню».
Знала всі три голоси і давала така:
«Оце ви співаєте цим голосом, ви — оцим, ви — оцим».
Казали: «Дівчата, так а давайте хоч назву якусь».
То «Калина», то «Малина»,
то ще щось придумували.
А хто сказав «Древо»,
я не можу сказати...
Може Галина Якимівна і сказала.
Хай буде «Древо», бо у нас [є] пісня —
«Ой, у полі древо».
♪ Ой, у полі древо, ♪
♪ Що тонкоє да й високоє. ♪
[співають]
Галина Якимівна багато зробила для «Древа»,
для народної пісні.
Я завжди говорила на чоловікову
матір «мама», бо своєї я не знала.
Моя загинула, коли бомбили Гребінку.
Дитинство моє пройшло,
звичайно, те, що я пам'ятаю,
то це війна, більше нічого.
Але я ніколи не бачила свого батька, ну правда.
Як я [народилася] 1937 року,
а в 1941 році батько пішов на фронт.
Якщо було мені чотири роки,
то нічого не пам'ятаєш.
Ну ось ці — короткі, а як довші і більші,
то я оце сідаю і...
Ото я подушки повишивала...
Вовки, кажуть, на щастя.
Я дуже люблю українські народні пісні, дуже.
Ще, я ж кажу, була в бабусі,
це в сусідньому селі — у Березовій Рудці.
Ми було полягаємо на печі,
і вона вчить мене пісень.
♪ Ой, гаю, мій гаю, ♪
♪ Гаю зелененький, ♪
♪ Чом на тобі, гаю, ♪
♪ Листячка нема? ♪
♪ Чом на тобі, гаю, та й листячка нема? ♪
Кс-кссс... Що тобі дати?
Їсти? Зараз дам. Іди до мене.
Збиралися спочатку так, по хатах.
Наприклад, зарізали порося.
Давай свіжину жарить, сусідів гукали.
Зібралися в них, у нас, ще в когось.
Сідають у хаті, гуляють свіжину і співають.
♪ Я в Сорочинцях на ярмарку була,
Я в Сорочинцях на ярмарку була. ♪
♪ Я на ярмарку була і телицю продала,
Я на ярмарку була і телицю продала. ♪
♪ Як продала я телицю... ♪
Приїхав із Києва Володимир
Матвієнко з консерваторії,
він збирав народні пісні.
Це був 1957 чи 1958 рік.
— Ти з курткою чи без?
— Ні, з курткою, куртка в мене.
Ми ж будемо йти пішки.
— Як я молодша, так я ззаду?
— Так, ти ззаду.
— Я ж бігом!
— Чого?
А того, що треба спішить.
Жінки у полі пололи і сіли на обід.
А він ходив, ходив до того ж босий.
І коли він послухав, як вони співають,
він сказав: «Так це ж Грузія!»
Бо в нас поліфонічний спів у три голоси.
— А куди ви?
— Вона в магазин хоче по хліб.
— Ну, Ніна і Галя пішли.
— А куди ви йдете? Йдемте!
Так я зараз по хліб збігаю і назад.
Галина Якимівна — «брало»,
Пріська Загорулькова — «тягло».
У нас воно називається «тягло»,
«брало» — другий, а ці — «третій».
Буде нас і 20 чоловік, але всі мають третім співати.
♪ Ой, у полі висока могила, ♪
♪ Ой, у полі висока могила. ♪
І так ми організували це «Древо».
І в 1960 році вперше Валя Пономаренко нам каже:
«А якби ви виступили десь у клубі?»
Давайте!
У нас ото три мужики: це тьотки Пріськи
Загорулькової — Василь Федорович,
тоді мій чоловік — Федір і Галини Якимівни — Толя.
І ми виступили в клубі.
[аплодують]
[співають]
Ну перше, це — Польща, Франція, Угорщина...
У Німеччині дуже гарно.
Пішли ми в їдальню, а там ящички такі,
там кожне зернятко окремо.
В Угорщині так взагалі: заходиш в їдальню
і накладаєш, що тобі там подобається.
Ось в Угорщині Міклош нас забрав.
Тоді з Угорщини в Польщу перелітали літаком.
Із Польщі — в Київ, у Києві виступали в консерваторії.
Із Києва — у Чернігів, там виступали.
[співають]
У кожній державі так уже люблять народну пісню нашу!
Ми в селі часто виступаємо,
у сусідніх селах ми виступаємо.
Я кажу: «Микитівна, та ми знаємо ті пісні,
давай не той...»
«Та ні, давай повторимо, давай зійдемося, повторимо».
І так відпочиваємо.
Тут ще одна думала йти ж цибулю вибирати,
тоді глянула, а вже початок шостої, ой матінко!
А що, ти вже цибулю вибираєш?
— Та сіянку!
— А, сіянку... У мене нема.
— Я її рано посадила.
— А я не сію, я вже не хочу за нею турбуватися.
Воно таке нещасне.
— Ну а садити чим?
— Та, діти куплять та і все.
— Доброго дня, вітаю!
— Добрий день!
— Зі святом!
— Зі святом! Сьогодні?
— Ну так у тебе ж свято?
— Так-так!
♪ Ой, Тетяно, Тетяно, в тебе в хаті погано, ♪
♪ Я підмажу, підведу, в хаті буде до ладу, ♪
♪ Я підмажу, підведу, в хаті буде до ладу. ♪
♪ Жаль мені на Тетяну, жаль мені на її, ♪
♪ Що не дала повечерять бідному сироті, ♪
♪ Що не дала повечерять бідному сироті. ♪
♪ Що не дала повечерять, та й не дала ложки... ♪
♪ Ой, чого ж ти больной став, та скажи, скажи, ♪
♪ Да мій друг розлюбезной, ♪
♪ А коли будеш поми... ♪
Слова пропустила.
Кажу: «Коли будеш помирать».
Раніше були такі пісні, що ой...
Воно береться мабуть із життя:
як жили люди, тепер же таких пісень немає.
Бо ми ж тепер живемо...
Та ну, тепер такі пісні...
♪ Ой, давно-давно в матінки була, ♪
♪ Що вже та й доріжка терном заросла. ♪
♪ Ой не так терном, як шипшиною, ♪
♪ Де ми походили із матінкою. ♪
Оце ми так і на репетицію їздимо, і з репетиції.
І з репетиції, репетиції були різні.
[сміються]
— Значить так, на шосту годину. А куди?
— Сюди.
Пока! До завтра!